so many creative people talk about the
importance of failure right the fact
that it's okay to make mistakes during
the creative process than to do anything
creative you've got to take a risk some
kind of cognitive dissonance is
necessary you need to cross the streams
you need to cross the wires just a
little bit right a little bit of madness
is necessary to connect the dots in a
new way right Isaiah Berlin famously
said to understand is to perceive
patterns that's in essence what
creativity is Steve Jobs says creativity
is just connecting things but in order
to see patterns and rather in order to
recombine existing patterns into new
forms and new shapes you need to be
willing to blur the boundaries between
your thoughts right to be an
associational thinker right to free
style to ride a butterfly affecting
thought but again most of the time we
play it safe right we map out what we're
gonna say we pre plan what we're gonna
do we make a list we have a set of steps
we are prepared we've pre-scripted our
speech right we are responsible we're
not going into a situation blind but
again once in a while my friends we need
to be willing to make a mistake we need
to be willing to fail it is only when we
risk making a mistake that we might find
ourselves improvising inventing
innovating our way back to where we want
to get to do you understand what I'm
saying
think of this rant as a metaphor for the
creative process right I have somewhat
an idea of what I want to say right it's
related to creativity and it's related
to cognitive dissonance and being
willing to make a mistake that's all I
know then they start jamming about this
and what happens is I might lose myself
in some chain of thought right I just
kind of lose myself in the moment the
metaphor might like confound me and
before I know it I don't even remember
what I was saying but somehow that's
when the creativity kicks in because
somehow I've got to bring it back I've
got a rope it in I've got to remember
where I'm going I've got some
incoherence right in the Bardot's
between one statement and the other and
in doing so and in risking screwing up
the video and the tape it is in that
risk that the courage that the
innovation that the creativity that the
original thought might emerge and
usually does and before I know it I've
landed and I feel like wow man I just
took a trip man you know I just sailed
into the great unknown and I brought it
back and here we are
that is what creativity is all about
that is the risk that is there be the
willingness to fail and make a mistake
that is crucial to the creative process
so there well my fellow thinkers writers
painters poets original doers out in the
world trying to come up with an original
vision trying to impact humanity through
their art and their artistry go forth
but be willing to fail be willing to
make a mistake
pick up the pieces and try again it is a
ride and we're all in it together my
friends and if we love each other and
respect each other and tolerate each
other's failures and failings we will
get to a much better much higher much
more holy place and isn't that awesome
even my dad like that who's watching
from the back
[Laughter]
you